قواتنا ليست
منخرطة ولن تشارك في
الصراع مع القوات الروسية في أوكرانيا
، لن تذهب قواتنا إلى أوروبا
لمحاربة أوكرانيا ولكن للدفاع عن
حلفائنا في الناتو في حال قرر بوتين
الاستمرار في التحرك غربًا
لهذا الغرض.
نشر الأسراب الجوية للقوات البرية لحماية دول الناتو ،
بما في ذلك بولندا رومانيا ،
ولاتفيا ليتوانيا وإستونيا
[تصفيق]
قبل ستة أيام سعى فلاديمير بوتين الروسي
إلى زعزعة أسس
العالم الحر
معتقدًا أنه يمكن أن يجعله
ينحني لطرقه المهددة
لكنه أخطأ في تقديره.
[موسيقى]
هجوم بوتين الأخير على أوكرانيا كان
متعمدًا وغير مبرر تمامًا ،
فقد رفض الجهود المتكررة في
الدبلوماسية
التي اعتقد أن الغرب وحلف الناتو لن
يردوا
، واعتقد أنه يمكن أن يقسمنا في المنزل في
هذه الغرفة في هذه الأمة ،
وكان يعتقد أنه يمكن أن يقسمنا.  في أوروبا
أيضًا
ولكن بوتين كان مخطئًا ،
فنحن مستعدون لأننا متحدون وهذا
ما فعلناه بقينا متحدين
[موسيقى
] أعلن أننا سننضم إلى
حلفائنا في إغلاق المجال الجوي الأمريكي
أمام جميع الرحلات الجوية الروسية مما يزيد من عزلة
روسيا ويضيف ضغطًا إضافيًا على
اقتصادهم
[موسيقى]
لقد تعلمنا هذا الدرس
عندما
لا يدفع الطغاة ثمن
عدوانهم  يسببون المزيد من
الفوضى يستمرون في التحرك